one thing we're seeing at CES this year
is that smart cars are the new
smartphones if you want proof of that
we're here a blackberry you probably
remember them from the phones with the
great keyboards now they're working on
software for vehicles grant you're with
blackberry nice to meet you absolutely
you took us through a little bit about
what you guys are actually working on
and what you're doing I mean we know
your per phone so my car
well communiques has been in cars in
automotive for about 20 years number one
market shared infotainment telematics
and Retin credible success in automotive
blackberry and unix coming together are
going to enable us at the connected car
as well as the autonomous car of the
future and make them safe and make them
security I mean I'll cause a big push
software and makers and is this becoming
an increasingly important market oh
absolutely so you're seeing more and
more software in vehicles today you're
gonna see more in the future you're
seeing automakers and best tremendously
in software software is going to be the
differentiation in the car it's gonna
help make cars safer make them more
secure ultimately it's what you need to
drive and get us to that self-driving
vehicle so talk us through a little bit
about what you guys are actually working
on what it's showing yeah sure what
we're showing here is a combination of
things the one in the Jaguar what we've
got is we have an integrated system that
provides an infotainment system and
digital instrument cluster that are
completely separated and secured all
being driven by the cutest platform for
entertainment yeah so it's a nice break
from the hubbub of the show to close the
doors on the apology car get a bit of
quiet for a minute you're showing your
software inside at Jaguar so what's
different about this what why is this
better than me so what we've done to
your point is we've replaced the
displays and whatnot and we're running
our kicks platform containment duty
platform for instrument clusters what
we're doing is actually we've
consolidated these onto one computer
system so normally you would have two
ECU's electron control units one for the
cluster one print wrote Ament what we're
doing is actually combining them into
one and making use of the communiques
hypervisor so we can actually separate
and isolate the cluster from the digital
that's the cluster is the one in front
of me you know we've got like these are
some safety critical things telling us
about you know the car and speed limit
this is where the lights you indicate
everything which this is a pretty
critical screen to not have go wrong and
so these are normally built in a very
robust fairly simple way whereas what's
happening in the middle here this is
less critical right correct yes exactly
so this would for instance have your
warning light so your engine warning
light and whatnot those are deemed
safety critical elements your vehicle
your park where your what's called the
pendulum our cover's neutral Drive so
this is a traditional infotainment
system I guess that with running all of
our software and whatnot and so we've
added some things here which are
interesting so you can go to full screen
for a full screen map view if you want
nice you can also return yeah exactly
and you can actually go back you can
also flip these back and forth so you
can have the map down below and above
you'll never see this exact user
interface in a vehicle this is what we
provided the automakers on the tier ones
and then they'll go and they'll
customize it and so here's an example
Ford smart device link for instance that
we've integrated so we're connecting
through a handset to make that work
music so that's coming off of a handset
and actually through Ford's smart device
link connector UNIX cars retainment and
actually obviously pretty great it
completely integrated into the vehicle
but again you've got those risks if you
have a handset plugged in and obviously
this is this is a place where viruses
malware whatever else could be
introduced to exactly it you're having
to be presumably very careful but your
firewalling not away from the same thing
Figg exactly and that's what the
automakers and the tier ones absolutely
rely on us for is that separation that
isolation of these systems so that
malware cannot be introduced into the
vehicle when we see in some
very soon and you might see it in the
form of one large display you might see
it in more of a traditional format but
we're working with automakers now to
actually make this happen in the
next-gen vehicles